oh yeah it's capturing hi guys and girls
I am Wolf's coming right now cuz I'm
sick today and so I haven't taken care
of myself
because I don't know so I'm a little
scum bunny and also my apartment is also
kind of a reflection of how I feel on
the inside because I just got some new
furniture that guy and a couple other
things some rearranging things and
putting things up look at all those
books on the ground they're gonna go
somewhere at some point so just ignore
all of that stuff from drinking water
I'm trying to hydrate but I did go to my
co box today I don't know why I decided
to go when I felt so terrible because I
was sitting on the train and I was like
sweating so bad because my body's been
going through like getting chills and
then sweating a lot so it was a weird
experience but it made it feel like all
this mail is like more deserved or
something like I went through a journey
to get it a journey that tried me
emotionally and physically it did also
don't smell good so there's that but
let's get into opening something yeah
should be yelling probably my throat is
sore okay look at these letters oh you
guys are so cool at sending mail it's so
exciting
Sarah baby woohoo from lancaster
california i like your last name it
seems really cute you look so pretty I
think I need that today for sure what
really is so sweet so this letter is
like almost hope and I bet the
post-office people wanted to read it
there's some nosey there no they don't
give [ __ ] about anything
welcome made of love and paper oh that's
cute what a clever space to write that
in ooh
Loosli paper green
later whoa grace I love your shows
you're super awesome and my best friend
watch your shows as soon as possible I
live in California
very cool we get your videos around 10
p.m.
oh yeah you guys kind of get them the
day before that's fun you are funny and
refreshing yay like um like Snapple
you know like Snapple facts are funny
and Snapple is refreshing I'm like
Snapple that's crazy
your youtube name is silly donek oh
that's cute
ooh it's not weird and stuff yo tumblr
calm well I hope you're having the
perfect day and I'll see you on YouTube
I'm having not the perfect day yes I'm
having the perfect day thank you so much
for this letter Sarah that was really
cool of you to take the time to write
that how sweet of you how sweet it is oh
you change that's uh uh Lindsey from
Santa Ana California
ooh let's see what is in sorry copped on
your letter that makes it mine okay oh
whoa something's falling out Wow oh my
god you send me a letter opener that
says Daily Grace but I think it's
literal yeah is it the letter O gonna
turn that is gonna come in so handy
thank you so much that's awesome hey
racist saw that you had to mess up some
envelope stuff I'm so I thought I would
send you a letter opener hope it helps
anyways your videos always brighten my
day ah you drew the little guide and
your hem writing penmanship is so
adorable
and I couldn't find paper so I gave you
some old history notes thank you
someone's got PowerPoint presentation
going on so that's awesome thank you so
much I'm gonna try and use this right
now I don't think I've ever used a
letter opener before um so let's try it
I'm a little nervous here's a letter
oh it's already started for me how do
you do it like this then you oh my god
it works so well it works so well thank
you okay this is from Madeline Heckman
from West Chester Pennsylvania ooh fancy
oh holy [ __ ] this looks bad no it
doesn't don't judge yourself it's a
thank you card and it's so formal and
pretty Dearest grace helbig's so formal
people in Westchester so fancy if you
get this gasps thank you card oh I take
that back what I said thank the friggin
Lord High okay let me get to the point
you are my hero oh my god my best friend
Julie Cuccia and I love Daily Grace so
cool Joy's birthday is August 23rd happy
birthday to you a little little if you
could send anything signed by you now
okay that's I would if I could but I
can't so instead I'll just say happy
birthday thank you so much for watching
my videos and thank you for this card
Westchester hope you guys are van fancy
and a little bit trashy out there I go
nuts all right what's next
thank you for that um this Daily Grace
male with stickers builders oh brother
a turtle not a ninja but purple whoa is
that us haiku a little hi cute a little
hi cute go little letter opener watch
this oh and then so we're running it
even with the letter O oh and I ruined
it even with the letter opener
am i doing the letter opener wrong oh
shoot
I'm doing the letter opener room
let's try take it from grace it's not
being stupid ah we salvaged it establish
it whoa oh my gosh what is this okay a
pee-pee
this is uh is this a Pokemon named pipi
that's cool when I was younger I had an
invisible friend named pipi not a joke
that is a true fact who is this from
hi grace I didn't want to just send your
boring letter so I searched around the
house for stuff I found some money from
China what you sent me money from China
oh my god you did send me money from
China oh I'm so rich in China look at
this look at Chinese money is so
beautiful I think it's beautiful it's
just it's different and they have
waterfalls on it oh whoa Chinese money
I'm gonna buy so many egg rolls that
racist to say I really enjoyed watching
your show thank you so you you oh you're
so anonymous you don't have your name
anywhere you are so anonymous it's and
you have a pet turtles you like turtles
a lot you're just trying to fill the
paper thank you so much for the Chinese
money and for this little peepee
character that's adorable and for your
anonymity I will forever wonder who you
are excuse me gross oh my gosh and they
continue what is this oh these are more
from Zoey it's always been sending me
postcards almost every day or something
crazy like that and so she sent me I'm
another one
uh-huh
Thank You Zoe for this this is San Diego
look everyone on the beach in San Diego
is having fun on the beach in San Diego
yeah clipper kill who's this from this
is from I can't read your name angle
bill is mine 24 I don't know what that
is just sitting in my room in Paris
wasting money on a postcard whoa what a
tough life and I thought you should get
some international posts oh so cool
are you Parisian are you just visiting
and I thought that if you Tosh and bo
burnham ever got together and did a bit
that would be the happiest day of my
entire life
well I'll talk to them and see what they
say and then I'll get back to you
because that would be amazing
oh I've been to Paris I'm in there and
it is beautiful and fun are you having a
good time there cool good eat the
baguettes and the wine is so cheap it is
like two dollars for a bottle of wine
Paris wants you to get boys food whoo
Liz here's a postcard from Liz and it's
Point State Park in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania so many peas look at that
I've never seen that I've been to
Pittsburgh a couple times and I never
saw that I bought Oh
a Pittsburgh postcard for $1 because I
thought they were funny after going
through them I found that not anywhere
they were dated some also I mean I'm
photos that you would enjoy the Point
State Park fountain awkwardly shot from
above I'm bad at reading but thank you
so much for this list I do enjoy it this
is a cool postcard looks so vintage so
vintage and oh my gosh from the San
Diego Zoo I like your style look at that
why would they do this
I don't understand why they'll put four
pictures of the same animal that is a
very vain and postcard for this animal
whoa who's this from
hi grace you've been hurt ah oh it's
from Zoe again Zoe
risk Zoe this might be the first one
that you sent that it got haha thank you
so much so this is the hilarious
postcard what else we got this guy this
feels heavy and this is my sticker
face.com
what is that from neskowin cent New York
my sticker face back on this is a cool
envelope I like whatever it is and
there's a sticker
I'm assuming you work for this company
my sticker face.com 100% recycled paper
and chipboard oh that's so great
I love recycle paper go letter opener
don't be a [ __ ] how it works nailed it
on that one
whoa what is all of this in here well
what is this my sticker face calm what
no oh my god I'm dying and then it
stickers Michelle's face oh my god this
is hilarious
oh my who did this who did this to me
and it's my sticker face calm guys go
check out my sticker face calm I guess
holy crap oh here's the letter
greetings grace my name is April's guard
doozy oh and I am a social media manager
at my sticker phase calm we're sending
you some sticker phases try not and
hopefully for you to talk about them
with your friends and fans of you doing
a wednesday review I'll never blah blah
blah blah blah oh my god this is
hilarious my sticker face calm you guys
you guys they make stickers out of our
faces I'm gonna Michelle and I are
definitely gonna do something about
these but please you can go make
stickers out of your face guys mr. Graff
acecomm come I said it enough yeah I've
set it on and also this paper is so cool
go check it out y'all
oh and oh my gosh if you use the code 15
off one five OSF you get 15% off your
entire order holy crap
Ola oh my god 15 off one five Oh ffs Wow
cool guys go get some stickers that's so
cool
Thank You April from my sticker Faceman
show and I will definitely have to up
have to do something with these those
are so fun okay
oh also someone sent me um a Crate and
Barrel
magazine and I love it done awesome what
a great magazine great read great summer
reading betrayed you guys go to the
beach anytime soon check it out a road
this thing is from Dylan Ricci in
Montreal Quebec boo my heart will go on
no she's from there I can't think of her
name right now what's her name Celine
Dion Celine good no Celine yeah go a
letter opener I'm just doing this letter
opener wrong I think
oh whatever
whoa whoa well we went whoa greetings
from Canada hello gracious that I send
you a package you just I think you're an
amazing person and think your videos are
Baccarin hilarious how so cool oh my
favorite to this day would have to be
the macaroon review yeah Danny macaroons
delicious whoa
and you made all the icons oh so cool
you did a great job they look awesome
their little costume um I can't seem to
get my 16th birthday is coming up on the
26th of August are you sure
do that other girl happy 16th birthday
and I can't seem to convince my mom to
get me an A you've been hazed t-shirt
online size small I was just wondering
if you could send me one in the mail
oh no no when you put money in here no
okay um
shoot all right this is okay I'm
actually glad this happened cuz I need
to tell you guys one please don't send
me money in the mail because I don't
like having to buy you shirts it's not
my responsibility
sorry to get motherly for a second but
oh man but you did give me piss piss
piss this you can send me I like candy
I like Pez but please still make me buy
your shirts for you oh my gosh I'm such
a look at my apartment they should give
you some clue as to how disorganized I
am in everyday life okay oh and you keep
me what you gave me Canadian money -
what missus do it oh man Dylan you are
so sweet oh shoot alright I'll figure
something out um Thank You Dylan for the
Pez
that's so sweet of you okay what's next
next we got this guy from Alain candle
right something like that
Canada Lee from Denton Kansas I think KS
that stands for Kansas right maybe hey
go go package go package we're using the
crap out of my new opener huh well well
we weren't well okay hey grace I don't
know about you but I like miniature
stuff so when I saw these tiny chemist
says I had to
of them I thought I'd share the joy with
you and paint you something real nice I
hope you like them and your videos keep
them coming
Elaine C oh my god I'm so excited
go so much tissue paper Oh cry me a
river because I got tissues for days Wow
oh my god oh my God look at that that is
adorable holy crap that is so cute oh my
god that is so cute
oh it's so cute and it's cute and it's
so cute oh my god cute overload calm
it's so cool oh my good Thank You Elaine
that's awesome that is so neat oh you
guys just spoil the crap out of me okay
last but not least this guy from Alicia
Garcia from Houston Texas oh it's a
little Cuban it's got this this on the
outside which I don't I don't know what
that is maybe you guys know what it is
but I don't go little paper letter
opener you're working so well now what's
that say on it let's say [ __ ] no what
is it safe better find out grace I love
your videos I wanted to send you
something customized and
then made before at least I hope not I
have been making shirts for a little
while now and design screamed you
something oh my gosh that's right
designed and made myself I'd mess
InDesign off to be printed by someone
else lame I am a one person clothing
company called errata clothing II are
are a tee a pronounced air rata you make
all my friends laugh oh sorry I know
this is so nice oh the packages are
always wrapped and sealed with many
different colors of wax the website for
the shirts is errata clothing calm ER
our ATA
clothing calms holy crap um look at this
okay so it's wrapped in twine which I
always love twine because I think it's
like cool and it's got a little oh it's
got a little wax seal that's what that
is
that's so cool we're doing to break it
but I'm gonna break it
oh my gosh oh my gosh I'm already
freaking out I'm having a mmm sorry that
was my throat mucus oh I am so excited
and I just can't hide it oh look at that
how cool is that this is so cool oh my
gosh this is so cool it says what's up
[ __ ] and then it says Daily Grace on
the other side this is so cool thank you
oh my gosh I'm dying Alicia thank you so
so much guys go check out
Arata clothing comm right and make sure
I get that right you are are HEA
clothing calm so cool and it's from
Cristina Rodriguez also thank you so
much around a clothing around a clothing
my sticker face
lol and see oh look at you guys are the
coolest people in the history of the
world even better like King Arthur
probably wasn't this cool o at all not
even close thank you guys so so much oh
I'm going to go take some more medicine
because all this excitement has caused
all the mucus in my body to go and just
attach so thank you guys so so much this
is so cool and I'll see you later